trois victoires trois matches
laissez moi tout le temps aller voir un
avocat
la fausse monnaie ça m'intéresse pas
j'ai une proposition à te faire
c'est quoi cette même c'est juste une
gamine elle est arrivée à moins d'un an
attends tu veux venir avec moi
franchement trouve moi qu'il a vendu là
bas elle t'aidera à t'orienter pourquoi
des jetons et le fatah sont pas mal de
bruit je conseillerais pas que fait
christian thibault grac salon mais
titanesque
derguy friends of earth wyplay gipsy
long terme à la côte est puisque comme
ça qu'on les y génome est produit le
prof monde en titre de la coupe grey se
montrent ouverts
deux protos coulisses du mois 10 km
approprié agrège kata si nice comme est
reparti ok c'est juste besoin que tu
m'aides ces restes ici elle va pas s'en
sortir faut qu'ils retournent en france
aie aie aie
je te contacte rigolote
tu vas voir tout ça